So, here on the reel you can see the top end,
a really beautiful sample  of research quality Platinum.
- Platinum is a very heavy metal and it is like silver and gold.
It’s a metal which does not  easily react with the oxygen in the air.
So, if you make jewelry out of it, it stays nice and shiny and looks nice.
Platinum, unlike gold is, has a silvery color which some people like.
You can make alloys of silver and... of Gold and Platinum
which will have different colors of yellow depending on your taste.
- Platinum is a very very precious metal. It's of very very high value
not just for jewelry, but also for the production
of auto-catalytic converters and other chemical processes.
This wire here is very very fine. It's 0.01 millimeters in diameter
and it is used to study vapor phase and gas phase chemistries.
- Platinum is found in a number of places around the world, for example, in South Africa.
But, it's of very small amount, each ton of rock
may have as a little of 7 grams of Platinum in it.
So, you have to break an awful lot of rock to get this material.
In recent years,  Platinum has become very important
in catalysts in cars. The catalytic converters
and so, more and more cars, infact all cars now have Platinum
in their catalytic converters. And, if we are going to go to
Hydrogen powered cars using fuel cells, these will probably also need Platinum.
In fact, that is a considerable question, whether there is enough Platinum
in the world to frill the uses we want to put it is to.
This is 1 gram, there. 1 gram of Platinum.
Captions by www.SubPLY.com